بعدما وصفوها بالمهزله التامه يرفض نقبات
العاملين او ترفض نقابات العاملين في
بريطانيا المشاركه في عمليه لاعاده النظر
في الاجور قائله اي النقابات العماليه ان
عمليه اعاده النظر في الاجور ليست مستقله
واعلنت انها لن تمتثل لطلبات الحصول على
ادله لادخالها في الحسابات المتعلقه
بالدفع لعمي 2023 و 2024 قبل ذلك دخل
موظفوا الاسعاف اضرابا اليوم الاربعاء مع
تحذير المواطنين من توقع حدوث تاخيرات في
حال احتاجوا لتلقيمات الطوارئ وتطالب
المجموعات العماليه برفع الاجور والحكومه
ترد بضروره الالتزام بالتوصيات طبعا
الوزراء هنا يصرون على انه يجب عليهم
الالتزام بالتوصيات التي قدمتها الهيئه
المسؤوله عن مراجعه اجور العاملين في هيئه
الصحه العامه و وفقا لاحصائيات وارقام
بريطانيه فان نحو 20 الفا عمال وموظفين
اسعاف في كل من انجلترا وويلز مشاركين في
الاضراب المعلن هذا عن العمال اما الحكومه
فقد صعدت المستوى لهجتها ضد العمال سواء
في التمريض او قطاع النقل حتى وصلت مرحله
التهديد بفصل عمال وتعهد رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشي سوناك بالمضيق قدما في
تطبيق قوانين جديده صارمه للحد من سلطه
النقابات وتقتضي حدا ادنى من موظفي
الاسعاف ورجال الاطفال
والسكك الحديديه اثناء الاضراب اما وزير
الصحه البريطانيه فااا المواطنين الى
استخدامه وصفه بالمنطقه السليم للتعامل مع
اضراب عمال الاسعاف مشددا على ضروره
التعامل مع الحالات الخطره فقط